we're going to begin this hour with NASA
planning to launch its Artemis 1 moon
mission this Saturday we're taking a
look back at a key moment in the history
of the Space Program Ed Dwight Jr was
almost the first black astronaut in
space he was selected by President John
F Kennedy to join the astronaut program
but was not ultimately picked for the
fame
1969-69 Apollo mission to the moon so
you may be wondering like I was why are
we doing a story about someone who
almost was well National correspondent
jerika Duncan spoke with Mr Dwight about
how that changed his life and his
mission
I sat down at the table over there to to
get it ready for casting inside 88
Ed Dwight's art studio in Denver
Colorado is a collection of stories told
through the sculptures he creates this
is one of the Buffalo Soldiers he was
Corporal Clinton Greaves and he was one
of the 18 Medal of Honor winners during
the Indian fighting days but before
Dwight became an artist dedicated to
memorializing notable figures in black
history he had hopes of making history
of his own in space
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard when President John F Kennedy
decided to take one step for man he also
made plans to send the first black
astronaut to the moon and thought Ed
Dwight was a star when I got this letter
in November the 4th 1961 offered me this
opportunity to be the first negro
astronaut I thought these dudes were
crazy
why me I mean what in the world is this
all about you know and I said no I mean
my first reaction to it was that's the
nuttiest thing I ever heard at the time
Dwight was a 27 year old Air Force pilot
who had to be convinced to take the leap
I consulted my mother and my mother's
telling me about all this stuff stuff
that I can do as a symbol and think of
you know all the kids you'll get excited
your mother tells you this is bigger
than you this is you representing
African-Americans exactly this is
definitely the sign of progress for the
Negro in the country as the first
African-American astronaut candidate
Dwight was considered a source of Pride
within the black community he toured the
country promoting his Newfound Journey
but when he returned to the Space
Program he faced a new frontier of
opposition so all these white folks that
I'm dealing with I mean my peers and the
leadership was just horrified at the
idea and the president appointed me to
this position you were known as the
Kennedy boy yeah it was the Kennedy boy
after four years of intense training
NASA decided Dwight did not have what it
took to be an astronaut the man dubbed
Kennedy's boy was quickly brought down
to earth why aren't you an astronaut now
well I couldn't begin to tell you
astronaut dreams dashed Dwight left the
Air Force in 1966. he worked at IBM and
started several businesses including a
construction company every evening I
would go to each one of my sites and all
the copper and the steel and pieces of
stuff that were left over and I throw
them in the back of my Mercedes and I'd
go home and then I had to teach myself
how to weld one person who took note was
his friend in Colorado's first black
lieutenant governor George Brown who saw
Dwight's work and encouraged him to
pursue it seriously George has been one
of my parties and saw this art in my
house and they wanted to do a sculpture
of me for the capital and I said well
that's not what I do and he says you're
going to become one of the famous
sculptures in the United States of
America when I get through with you
and I laughed at him I said George
you're full of stuff since then Dwight
has created nearly 20 000 Gallery pieces
and more than 130 memorials across the
country honoring those hidden figures of
black history I had never sculpted
before I was 45 years old like this he's
averitt Memorial is the one he
he says state capital
image of the people of the Texas
Memorial and they all have different
personalities and they all had have
different dreams and I wanted to put
that in their faces
a long way from space these sculptures
give us a better sense of the world in
which we live had you been the first
black astronaut into space you know I
probably would have done the same thing
the black guys did go into space you
know and that became the highlight of
their life experience because I wouldn't
have done anything I probably wouldn't
have done anything else does it still
bother you today that you were not the
first
that didn't bother me uh you know it you
know it was a great opportunity and all
the little parts and pieces of
everything you see in this studio and
all those buildings down there is a
manifestation of what I learned uh in
the years that I was in that program
what do you want your legacy to be you
know the Legacy I want is that I gave a
damn
and that's it a legacy sculpted by the
history he's determined to preserve for
CBS mornings jerika Duncan Denver
Colorado
I like him a lot I like that Legacy
too I was thinking Mr Dwight we might
steal that one but I think it's so
interesting you know they always say
when one door closes another one opens
because certainly he wouldn't be doing
that and he's really very good Oprah
often says God Can Dream a bigger dream
than you can dream for yourself when you
look at that you see it's amazing yeah
when one door closes the window opens
and that he is incredibly talented as a
sculptor I mean those figures are so
realistic absolutely true but you know
Tony when you get rejected that way
you're not thinking oh something better
is coming along it's still a very big
block I'm sure there were some low
moments there but it worked out okay it
worked out just fine and by the way it
wasn't mentioned in the piece but he's
been married for 56 years that is also a
heck of an accomplishment I like that I
like it as well